good afternoon welcome to this uh
meeting of the performance policy and
partnerships committee
um
welcome on zoom councillor abbott
we have an apology from councillor keith
it's a lot to move that's accepted
council lewis councillor soper i'll put
that all in favor all right against
carrie
uh
report from the invercargill youth
council oh sorry before we get into that
my apologies uh public forum we've got
uh south alive who've come along to
present to us on their achievements over
the past while uh courtney beryl and
paul welcome along we might just need to
grab another chair to um
thanks courtney
please barrel thanks yes yeah
uh kia ora koto
um thanks very much for the opportunity
to speak with you today
just introducing as you said uh paul
siranka on my left and courtney ellison
and myself beryl wilcox we're
representing today's south alive and the
work we do
we just wanted to give you the committee
an update of the community-led
development projects and achievements
and priority focus
areas that we since we met with you last
year it's a year ago and we wanted to
keep you updated and keep telling the
stories
we continue to keep on telling our
stories to reflect the vibrant diverse
community that takes a lead in its own
future to achieve our combined mission
statement as you can see up there
our urban regeneration group covers the
whole of the 9812 area of south
invercargill that has now well over 18
000 residents and growing housing
developments
there's been a really deliberate
strategy to widen opportunities across
this area
um as these can be at times the
misconception that we're limited to
south city only so we've worked hard to
actually divert out across the whole
area
in our organization we've actually got
14 trust board members
all who have volunteers with a wide
range of skills and expertise we have
three operational staff as well as the
pantry manager and their employees
we've got over a hundred
always regular volunteers at any one
time but there's thousands of community
contributions and hours in-kind
donations along with really strong
support from businesses organizations
the schools and community members who
celebrate the social transformation
which is evident and this year we've
been really proud to be celebrating 10
years of south alive
our success is reflected by both the
social transformation
of um
increased pride well-being and safety
along with the physical gains that have
been made including from the beginning
the south city upgrade the zero rubbish
program that's still successfully
running community art with murals and
sculpture the russell square
improvements that is happening at the
moment as well as advocacy for improved
housing and sections
um as beryl said this year we are
celebrating um 10 years and as part of
this
burial and some of our volunteers put
together a little video commemorating
and reflecting back on um what's been
achieved in those 10 years so i don't
know if it'll work but this is just a
small snippet of a longer video just a
30 seconds or so from some of the key
people that um have been part of south
of life's story
[Music]
[Music]
it's been wonderful for seeing the
community um
realise they can have a voice the goal
of the south the south city shopping
area was total transformation nothing
less but we started by picking at
rubbish which is people who are willing
to get stuck in and
do something and make it work
and good to see the way
over ten years you wouldn't recognize
the placement totally different
so as i said that's just a small snippet
of a longer video so there's about a
four minute video if you want to check
out our website or our youtube page you
can watch the whole thing but that is
just a few snippets of people telling
the story of the transformation that has
happened and how it's really
how it all really started
let me switch now
oh there we go um so just um to give a
wee update of some of the things that
have been happening since we last came
and spoke with you um
at the pantry our social enterprise
there's been a few things happening um
even with all the challenges of covert
we've been able to keep our village
markets going over the summer months
we've set up a recycle station that's
really important and comes through
strong as sustainability from the
feedback we get from
our volunteers in our community so this
recycle station has been set up it
collects milk bottle tops bread tags can
tabs
and they'll get turned into various
products and support different causes
um also as part of managing covert we
had to put a wall between our cafe and
store part of the pantry um
and while it wasn't great to have to put
a wall up but what actually presented an
opportunity to bring some art into the
space so south and art society um had
various artists that came along and
displayed their artwork that was
available for people to purchase but
also just brightened up the space and
what could have always been
yeah not such a nice thing to put a wall
through the middle of the space
um
aside from the pantry there's been lots
of other things happening um some
pictures up there show a cleanup day
that we held um this was something that
was really common in the first sort of
early years of south alive and it was
nice to sort of come back to doing some
of those working bees cleaning up the
streets so that was um done in the south
city area but we're looking to do that
quarterly and to do it in different
parts of south invercargill that the
community identify could do with a bit
of a clean up
there's some of our youth events the
three by three basketball
our world kindness day which has become
an annual
um event now on our calendar um and
there's some cookies there that um the
firmware primary students made so we
have lots of people contributing to
these events it's not just us running it
we had firmware with primary providing
cookies aurora college students
made soup various businesses and
individuals came together to put on
things that were free for our community
that day
and there you'll see some of our pay it
forward work um so we've got to pay it
forward volunteer team there's a team of
knitters who knit all those woolen goods
that are given to the hospital and those
are the christmas hampers that were
given to families um that needed them so
um that's part of our pay it forward
food boxes
okay
i'm pressing the wrong button now
there we go oh there's a few pictures
that have dropped off but um so a few
more things we've just updated our
website um with some more functionality
so people can sign up to volunteer with
us online they can book our community
rooms online uh they can donate to us
online and we've also set up a platform
in the background for our volunteers to
sign in and be able to connect with each
other for us to track the volunteer
hours
a bit better so we can see just the
magnitude of effort that's going into
all the work that and all the work that
our volunteers do um
we've also unveiled the first panel on
our heritage trail that we're developing
across south invercargill and so you can
see there the um
the panel at the world
the war memorial in south invercargill
um that was the first one that is
unveiled and what will be eight or nine
panels throughout south invercargill
and make a nice sort of one hour walking
loop for families
to to walk around
um we've had to adapt quite a bit
obviously with covert and running some
of our events differently we'd usually
have a really big children's day in
trolley derby at elizabeth park and down
rimu street um that couldn't happen this
year but we didn't want to cancel
completely so we just adapted how we ran
it and some of the activities we would
have had at the park we put into little
activity packs which you can see a
picture of there
and we handed those out on a on
children's day in march so families
could do those activities together
and there is another example with the
storybook that we've got along one of
our new fences
um
in our community park and so we've
partnered with the macagal library to do
that so you walk along the fence line
and you can see the panels each panel is
a different spread of
a children's book and you can read this
story as you walk along we've actually
just replaced it with the matariki story
for our upcoming
event
um we've had um concerts for youth with
that we partnered with public health
south on
we've done some upgrades to the
fence we've got a new community mural
that gives a bit of a sign letting
people know that we've got a community
garden there so that's a new mural on
our shed um and that's one of our school
holiday activities there too some
dadanga some weaving that we did
um so that's just a little bit that's
just a snapshot really of what's
happened in the last 12 months um
and then looking forward to some of our
future priorities these are things that
are identified by our community that are
important to them and that there's a
really strong emphasis on having more
opportunities for our young people and
so we have been doing a little bit of
work in that space and with some support
through the icc wellbeing fund and the
tomato fund we're running a lot more
events in the school holidays and some
youth gaming and that kind of thing but
building on that we've recently obtained
some funding from the voter found
foundation
to support some
trialling of some initiatives for
rangatahi so we've got some sort of key
themes around the trials that we'll be
running around improving access so
that's transport
physical access and also digital access
developing a bit of a tech club and
developing some tech skills
providing the opportunity to showcase
the talents of youth in our area and
connecting with employment opportunities
so for example through our social
enterprise and providing some work
experience opportunities um and so this
week we'll be putting out a an advert to
recruit for a youth coordinator to
deliver these trials
and so their role will involve engaging
with the young people in our community
to shape what these trials look like
delivering them and and learning from
that and seeing what we could carry on
with
one of the other priorities and things
are getting underway shortly is a review
of the facilities that are available in
south invercargill obviously we've got a
great space where we are and there's a
lot of other great spaces across the
south in vicargo area but they're not
always known about or known
where they are how they can be used and
so we're just doing a bit of a review of
that and meeting with the different
organizations in these facilities to
understand what is available um
connecting with different organizations
that might not have their own facility
and seeing what their needs are and
looking to the future around what might
be needed
and this will be really useful
information for us but also for i
imagine many others so we'll be happy to
share that information
and that will help us to to hold more
events and activities in local areas and
utilize existing facilities across our
area
one thing we know and we hear a lot is
that transport is a real barrier so if
we can hold things more in the local
places
even within the south invercargill area
that can be really helpful for getting
people engaged in things
oh thank you
it's rather hardy to follow uh so so
like we spend quite a bit of time on
consultation talking with our community
and listening to them and these core
items that are on the sport at the
moment are the things that keep coming
back to us from our community that they
wish us to improve on and to continue
with
so we adapt those
[Music]
slightly as regards to how they're
delivered and where they are delivered
so
along with that uh people wanted more
high quality enjoyable events now it's
quite difficult with cobra but we've
managed to do that so far they also want
to feel safe
in our community and that's a sense of
security with it wherever they are
and one of the things that you know
not that long ago that our community
constable was transferred and there was
actually quite a gap in there
and we got a lot of feedback about that
i'm happy to say that we have a new
community constable but that that sense
of um
of having that backing and that
community involvement someone that they
could approach and deal with things
before they got out of hand and had that
quiet word was quite important to our
people
we're looking at
continuing our
beautification program which is really
around our streetscapes and
and how we can provide extra pride and
that people feel in the community a
sense of ownership and along with that
of course comes the ability to uh to
change the direction i suppose of of
what's been going on in the past our
rubbish uh suggested is far lower than
it's ever been and that's an indication
that people in the community are saying
hey pick that up
look after that you own it don't leave
it
all right so when we're talking about
the youth we're providing as courtney's
just said some extra activities and
we're targeting that group targeting
we're focusing on that a little more
there are a lot of activities with
regards to youth taking place seems that
there's lots of organizations involved
but this one's from the bottom up not
from the top down
our housing groups morphed a little bit
as
there's been improvements made in
certain areas of it and commend the team
from council who's looking after those
sections and that they're in disrepair
and
rather unsightly and out of order but
we're talking more about sustainability
and about how that can happen in your
own place how you can look after
yourself in times of need and times
yeah adjusting to cover it again and i
think there'll be another again after
that so
after a lot of work we managed to keep
our doors open for all of our community
now it wasn't a small feat so we managed
to um set up a situation where we could
have
groups of vaccinated people who are
using uh public rooms
and uh on different occasions people who
weren't vaccinated
could also meet in those areas
they're separate not at the same time
but obviously there's a lot of work
around our staff and our people and
making sure that the cleanliness and all
those protocols are in place it's a
small facility
um it's not that small but uh but that
allowed us to have that bespoke sort of
operation taking place
so you would have seen that there were
pictures of our
path forward boxes and we delivered some
extra isolation packs to those in need
as well
i think that's
vitally important
looking at what's going on in the
community at the moment i think there'll
be a greater need before long so it's
about how we as a community address
those needs as well
with these
introduction of vaccine passes we have a
lot of people who don't have the ability
to
print download
and our team set up what they thought
was going to be a couple of hours where
people could come in and they could
assist them in laminate passes and
everything turned into a day in a bit
a flat stick with just a continuing
stream of people needing assistance in
that regard
and you'll see that adapting how we run
over our events and that's about having
smaller more bespoke events which are
actually in the areas so
instead of everybody having to travel
we're looking at how we can put them
into pockets in our community of
interest and that's why we're going
through that
looking at those facilities there's been
lots of facility
um
supposed to look at it
surveys done but actually this is about
what the owners or occupiers or the
controllers of those buildings
have available what they'll let use
their facilities because it is theirs
and how we can work together and
collaborate so that we can get better
use for them so the buildings are
utilized more and also we can get
into our own areas
rather than people traveling across town
we're running on our website we have
in the background we have an intranet
for our volunteers and that to relate to
each other
continue those connections
i think we're getting to the stage where
we've got more people isolated at the
moment
while there's restrictions removed we've
got groups who've
become
conditioned to not communicating with
others and to being more self
reliant well self-reliant or self
um
yeah it's probably the best way
right so we do
with the pantry which is our social
enterprise
so you know we've got 25 of our people
in our community roughly uh have a
disability
wherever you go in new zealand
so the pantry is a disability confident
employer
it operates the same regards with
volunteers provides opportunities
socialisation a whole lot more than just
selling goods
and i think
what's shown in the last year is that
these spaces are needed and this
connection is vitally important we have
a group of
core there's a few older members there
who this is their meeting point this is
their social connection
so it's far more than what we'd
normally have
we're also looking at
what we're doing with they've got a
newsletter going out and
that'll actually be a a drop a letterbox
drop
to everyone in the zone as well because
not everybody can be connected
as we normally see
over the barrel
just as an extra we found out yesterday
that we won the top shop award for the
pantry so we're thrilled about that it
gave us some
marketing um uh what would you call it
um
marketing package which was fantastic so
just coming to the end now um we
continue to be a voice for south
invercargill and wider strategic
engagement and discussions and we've
found of late that there's a lot of
discussion happening including with the
just transitions strong communities
murahaku the work stream that's
obviously being led by icc the mirahiku
regeneration worker transition
workstream then of course is the south
and regional skills leadership group
our approach is very much to share our
knowledge and learnings about
community-led development and the key
principles which underpin these actions
we also actively collaborate and consult
to achieve better outcomes examples of
these commitments include working with
manafenoua schools civil defence fiends
public health south active southland the
south and interagency forum vodafone
foundation department of internal
affairs and more it's really important
to collaborate to avoid duplication and
to work to get the best possible
outcomes
so
our wakataki there is a reflection of
many hands make light work and while
there might be only three of us here
presenting today everything we discuss
is a reflection of the hard work of
hundreds of people that come together to
build a stronger south and vocal
community and we've popped in some of
the events that are coming up in this
coming month the saturday our
mid-christmas midwinter christmas party
matariki event
we have meet the funders um and i
believe that icc
and different ones are coming so people
can go and talk to funders and crosswalk
so uh na mahinui koto and thank you very
much indeed
thanks beryl paul and courtney um i'd
normally open it up for questions but
we've gone well over time
certainly we value the fact you've taken
that opportunity year on to come along
and keep us updated we value your mahi
as well and thank you for the good work
that you're obviously continuing to do
through what's been a trying year but
congratulations on that success and look
forward to seeing you on saturday
thank you very much thank you
councillors that brings us to this time
the report from the invercargill youth
council uh katyana in nazir
welcome along
youth council and i'm just here today to
give a little update on the youth
council
and what we've been up to
so last month on saturday 14th of may um
our youth week committee collaborated
with u.n youth nz and we hosted a youth
who we event
um
we had
a good amount of participation probably
less than we anticipated but i do
notice
it was like a really short notice and
also covert play a lot
um during that time as well um
and the event was hosted by un youth but
um ran by
well who came along who came down from
auckland um we started the day with the
public speaking
impromptu just to break the eyes a
little bit and then we
got
to the main conversation of the day
which was
we talked about education mainly and
um just talked about the problems that a
lot of us experience regarding education
in invercargill especially and a lot of
them
a big part of it was about poor heating
issues at school
and just teaching quality at school and
just learning environment overall at
school
and it was just i thought it was very
interesting to see how everyone
had like different problems and just
different opinions regarding those
and um
overall i thought it was a really great
event it was very well planned so i
thought i thought the youth way
committee did really well planning it
and also notice um counselor sopra came
along that day as well so i thought i
hope it was enjoyable
and yeah that was from me
um
[Music]
i'm also from the invercargill youth
council
and
recently the youth council we've been
planning
and
deciding as a youth council we have
decided
to all collaborate
on hosting a candidates forum for the
upcoming election
and
um
we
are hoping to host this event at the
repertory theatre
and also we will be live streaming it so
that people from home or don't want to
go to a big event with covert can also
access it we're aiming this event
towards youth though
although we won't turn away anyone that
wants to attend
basically it'll be a q a session
type of structure but at the start there
will be a topic question
that
the candidates will have one to two
minutes
to sort of as an introduction that uh
topic question will be based around
youth and youth policy
as well um
yes along with
having it online live stream we'll also
be having an online
question
interface so
from the
audience or
from home you can
send in questions and they'll be asked
and so you can
if you're just not confident enough to
ask them yourself if you're in the
audience or if you're from home so you
can
hear the answers to your questions from
the candidates yeah um
we've thought about elements like food
and
basically the food is so that
it's sort of like a
cause for people to come along because a
lot of people aren't really
gonna spend two hours of a wednesday
evening
to come along to
said boring
event
but we're hoping to get many people
to come
and
almost aiming it towards people that
wouldn't normally come and diff and
aiming it towards seniors in high school
so we will be doing advertisement
through schools and online
trying to aim it towards that kind of
area in those people um
yeah we're still diving defining this
event and
look forward to seeing those who are
running for candice to see to come and
be a part of it but other than that
anything else that we have planned
or
are futurely planning will be on our
facebook page and instagram page so
yeah thank you
thanks karina and nasir councillor sopa
you were at the um
youth declaration howard do you want to
provide a quick bit of feedback on how
well the second or third year in a row
you've been a long time yes yes i i did
go i didn't go to the whole day because
i don't want to interfere too much in
your discussions
but the time i was there
i would like to say i was very impressed
with the
with the breadth and the in-depth
discussion that was taking place and the
honesty and open openness that was
taking place around the table i know
there was a little bit of disappointment
that there was a bit of a lesser turnout
but there were reasons for that and the
numbers who were there were certainly
having very
intense discussions which i thought
voted very well can i say not only for
the organization of the day
but for the future of what our young
people are contributing and will
continue to contribute to the community
because i thought if you if you all had
that level of discussion and some of you
were new to the council
at that stage
that it was looking very good for the
rest of
the time on the council and for your
future participation in
civics and civil
society so thank you for
letting me come along
thank you and thanks for extending the
invitation out to councillors as well
uh councillors we have the youth council
report if there are any other questions
counselor cricket did you want to move i
would like to move very delightfully i'm
really very much looking forward to the
candidate evening
second that thank you it's been moved
and seconded that the reports received
i'll put that all in favor
it's a compulsory chin in the clubhouse
well done steve
uh thank you very much for taking the
time to escape from school early and
come along in this uh summery afternoon
to present we we appreciate it
thank you thank you thank you thank you
councillors that brings us along to the
uh roaring 40s consultation rather than
going into
um the staff report first of all i
thought it would be appropriate that we
start with the submissions to be heard
and we have uh two of those
uh null thank you we are running uh 10
minutes behind time thank you for
persevering with us welcome along visa
everybody and uh
chair thank you
for the uh invitation to speak um
i do hope um the afternoon sees you all
well um and i would report that the sun
was shining in blood so
all was good um
what i wanted to say was that um the
roaring 40s entity i i actually think
it's a very good and important move
and that on the face of it it seems it's
going to be protecting the interests of
the ratepayers
which which i guess
is a very important thing
um so i would say that i i support the
proposal
um which i i
i think that you would welcome that but
i wanted to just add a few comments that
came to mind
um but the whole aspect of council
financial entities
um i think it needs to be
able to come under um better public
scrutiny
and to like to boost the rate power
confidence
a more um transparent and educational
drive
to help um understanding um these
financial entities how they fit together
i think would would have to be a good
thing for council um to consider
um and and one doing that consider that
there's also people that don't
have um good efficient um internet and
computers
um and and i just make the point that
i've got a reasonably good um computer
system and i'm i'm quite computer
literate but i did actually find it um a
little challenging
um actually finding the information and
that um was about the roaring 40s entity
and then when i did find that
had a flowchart
um diagram that i i couldn't really
actually make sense of so
i got in touch with one of your council
officers and
uh he was particularly helpful um he
explained to me and what what uh how it
all fitted together
um but as she pointed out that the play
chart actually wasn't quite correct
so um you know i was probably right
giving him a call
so i i just wanted to put that there for
you and
i'll leave it there um any questions and
thank you again for the opportunity
thanks noel it's open to questions now
from councillors
no there are none which means that you
get to enjoy that wonderful bluff
sunshine it's shining here in
invercargill as well it's just obscure
temporarily
lovely thank you very much buy some
nasty clouds thanks noel
rodney welcome along if you'd like to
come and take a seat
mr tribe submission is on page 11.
everyone knows me around here
obviously my submission was pretty much
that i couldn't agree with the proposal
um one of the reasons for that is i
don't think there was enough information
in there
for me anyone else to actually try and
get a grasp of what's the issue what are
the risks what are the advantages and
disadvantages
so
obviously
pulled the original consultation
document out
it came out and
i looked at it who drafted this
because we had a
company in there as hwcp roaring 40s
which clearly was a typo
we had
i think it was
what's still in there
electricity southern
which changed its name in december last
year
so look at that and go
want to consult on something you get
simple things like that wrong so
started doing a bit more digging
couldn't find the report the council had
requested that it was finally put up on
the website on the 20th
where the report said it would actually
be
maybe released with the consultation
document
technically you should release it with
it but then
went through it and had a
had a read and just came up with a heap
of different queries questions
and wondered how we got to the stage
of looking at risk so
i looked at it
and started going through
when i look at the consultation document
it said
that eil is a strategic asset
providing core
electricity infrastructure lines to
invercargill
eil owns the lines used to supply
electricity
goes on further to say strategic purpose
of eil
is electricity provisioned to
invercargill now i don't doubt that but
it's a bit more than that
council governance statement
says that eil
is to operate a successful electricity
distribution business but also invest in
the infrastructure
electrical and energy sectors
ichl statement of intent
says that eil is exploring ways in which
you can diversify its income away from
alliance due to the regulatory risk
associated with this
moving those assets away increases that
risk and i see nothing in here about how
they're going to
manage or mitigate
eils own
statement of intent
is to manage grow
and if appropriate
realize subsidiary joint venture and
associated investments in the
infrastructure electrical and energy
sectors
so
when i read in a document that
that's not its core business
and yet when i read in
the key documents that it is its core
business i go when it's called business
change
i also queried
because
the consultation document talked about
energy companies
the report you got talked about
electricity businesses they are
different
so i posed the question well
if they're energy companies you have to
consult on that i got told no no no
we're not talking about energy companies
we're talking about electricity
businesses
electricity businesses themselves aren't
exempt
bodied corporates that operate in
electricity business are
trusts that were set up for that are
otherwise
they're not
so like noel
i did a bit of a digging
to find
where the shares in this roaring 40s
energy limited partnership were knowing
that a limited partnership
doesn't have shares
it's a shareholder
in those companies it does
but
further to that
i tried to
work out what are the risks
in that original paper there was
the inherent risk of the investment
hasn't changed
the inherent risk might not be but other
risks could be
the risk to the investment in rf
r f e l p is reduced it's noted to the
extent that
r e re-e-r-f-e-l-p
may pose a risk to ichl
this may impact the ability of ichl to
support eil
now ichl provide the financing
and the treasury support
so if that impacts that
what impact does that have
on eil's
dividend
back to ichl and ichl's dividend
back to icc
i pose that question i just got told
that revenue doesn't change
revenue might not but the risk certainly
does
but i also read in there
that sglp was established in early 2015
and this was part of a package of agreed
changes
following the acquisition of otago net
there's a number of people around this
table
that are well aware of the
uncalled capital
consultation in the early years
and
that consultation was to purchase shares
and otago net nine and a half million
dollars worth which was subsequently
purchased sold
and then the investment
in sglp which actually created quite a
bit of a stink
around this table and i think some legal
opinions so
they weren't actually agreed at the time
and they weren't part of it
but i get through here and it talks
about
eil's ability
to actually be resilient in terms of an
earthquake or other natural disaster
will be enhanced
i struggle to see that
um
eoil again gets funding from ichl
how its ability to react and be
resilient
i struggle it doesn't shows its
substations
but not its lines
or its cables
i go even further into that and it
starts talking about
a passive investment
and therefore it should be held by the
holding company well that was never
agreed at the time
but then i look at it and go
but a target joint venture there's a
passive investment
they own less than a targo net than they
do in southern generation
otago net doesn't supply lines or
electricity to invercargill
neither does sglp
the risk of a target in a joint venture
would be higher than this
because they also don't insure their
lines or their cables
so i look at this and i go what are we
trying to fix
if it's a simple case of there's no
oversight or vision
into roaring 40s
change the soi of eil
you can do it under the act change it
make them report
and if you then want to get rid of it
get eoil to shift it instead of paying a
hundred grand to a consultant
the other one is
the formation of a cco
now i think your report today still
doesn't tell you whether it needs to be
one
i believe
the oag have said it does
but does that align with your partners
in terms of their reporting if not
how do you create a cco that has a
balance sheet dated 30 june
your partners
don't have that date
but i just look at it and go
there's not enough information
there's not enough
i would have put it
rigor
around the information provided i just
find it weak
and on that basis
i can't support it
thank you questions
councillor pottinger
uh thank you chair look rodney you
talked about the
i guess the uh
i'm going to use quality of the
consultation document in the sense of
providing the information that you would
seek
to make a decision now
you alluded to
our previous consultation for
electricity and that was back uh
i actually remember it very well in
october 2014
where it was found by our legal
representatives in the room that
council hadn't consulted adequately
and we
went back to square one and reconsulted
do you think it's deserving of that
degree of severity to start again and
consult um
well the the information that's there
unless you guys have a lot more
information and if you do i'd be very
disappointed because you should supply
information with a consultation document
but i can't see what the risks are
what the risk mitigations are
what the transfer of what that risk
might be to
ichl its dividends its ability for
funding but
if i look back over the last four years
i've seen
subsidiaries fail to keep the share
register it's breach of the companies
act
i've seen
the holding company not quite comply
with its constitution
and getting
counsel to approve things
if we talk about
and i do believe that there was three
years
post that consultation it took to get a
report from kpmg on that initial
investment
which highlighted some serious sort of
risk this is slightly different but i
don't believe that there's
anywhere near the information in here is
what this should be
but again i look at it and go
we had uncle capital
for certain things
that's now been changed when you moved
to lgfa
when you consulted on the uncle capital
10 million of that was a buffer for the
bank that buff is now gone it's 10
million you had 16.7 million dollars in
a ichl of redeemable preference shares
which you could have got interest on at
any time
technically it was alone when ichl was
set up in 1996.
you've turned those into straight equity
you've already given them 26 million
bucks
without consulting
i'm just looking at what i've seen over
the last three to four years it's a mess
tidying things up granted but when i
read a report like this
that
can't even get company names right
can't distinguish between
energy companies who puts energy
companies in a consultation document
then talks about electricity businesses
in a report
i'm just staggered to be honest i would
have kicked it to touch
thanks
thank you
further questions
uh thank you for your submission rodney
we appreciate it and for making the
drive up to present this afternoon
rhiannon and andrew
if you want to provide
[Music]
an overview of the um
the proposition and
with andrew and perhaps andrew there are
some questions around the
ichl perspective that have been raised
that you might like to
address as well
thanks randy
so um
cura councillors i'll take the report as
read
um
the consultation took place over the
period outlined
i will note that there was
an incorrect drive that was initially
loaded into the agenda but
that correction was made as soon as it
was drawn to
our attention
the information provided within the
document was aligned with the
risk profile that had been identified by
ichl which i know andrew will speak to
in a moment
um
consultation was promoted through a
number of sources we did receive three
submissions two of which you have heard
today on the balance of the issues
raised
the recommendation within the report is
that you proceed with the original
recommendation from ichl so
andrew
do you want to speak
to that
recommendation
um i'm happy to talk to it and look and
i thank the submitters for the
submissions that they're made and
because they'll raise uh legitimate
points and i think
uh starting with the lakeland issue i
suppose that really highlights one of
the issues that we're trying to address
here
um short of uh well
that is a subsidiary of eil
eil changed its name didn't inform us we
should have looked but it's an
indication of the fact that
things occur below eil
that the holding company really doesn't
have any transparency overall as a
result yourselves and so it's those sort
of minor things that come through
that highlight some of the issues that
we're trying to address
and i think the other key point uh of
distinction and as noted uh the comments
around what is in the ual
statement of intent and what is in the
holding company statement of intent but
it's that subtle distinction that
council and the holding company have
been working through around what we call
strategic events investments versus
commercial investments
and a lot of the things that eil
have expanded into and referred to
by mr tribe in the statement of intent
are what we have defined or agreed to
define as commercial investments and so
we're reviewing them and trying to
manage them in a different way so the
key strategic
investment for
the holding company and council in eil
remains remains the line business
and whilst
um eil
might in its stable intent say that it's
considering and
looking at developing other
opportunities outside that strategic
investment they've been reviewed in a
very different light to what they were
previously and in actual fact to be
honest we're looking at taking that out
of their statement of intent this time
around
so that's a matter of ongoing discussion
between the holding company and eil
in terms of the decision that council's
really been asked to consider uh i think
that the risks are really um
to be assisted at a group level uh and
again accepting mr tribe's comments and
they're right and they're matters that
were drawn out in the report but at a
group level there's no change in the
level of debt the asset transfers
and
the group dividend and etc will remain
the same because it's really an
accounting exercise in terms of the
ownership the business otherwise
continues on as as it was previously
there is the live question of whether or
not it's a cco and that is why council
consulted and again that issue was
identified in the paper
uh we raised again because ultimately we
will be guided by audit new zealand we
have a view um but we'll be guided by
all of new zealand on their opinion as
to whether or not it's a cco because
that drives a lot of the consequences
that mr tribe raised with you
we checked back with audit new zealand
again yesterday they still haven't
formed a view so the issue is actually
not that clear
um and we appreciate the consequences
and and the
angst that will provide our um relevant
partners if it is but does become a cco
realistically from our perspective uh if
it's a cco we're comfortable we operate
in a cco environment it doesn't uh
doesn't matter but there may be some
consequences as mr tribe pointed out in
terms of the accounting it's an
accounting exercise that we'll have to
go through if that occurs but ultimately
we're waiting on audit new zealand to
form a view on that
um so i think the
from from a group perspective
the issues are identified and the issues
are known um happy if there's any
further questions of running for the
clarification on them but um i think the
paper stands for itself
thank you councilor serpa
andrew when is audit new zealand likely
to form their opinion please
i wish i could answer that question um
they've been they've had the issue we
raised it with them before we started
this process because obviously we know
that this will be an issue for audit new
zealand one the whole transaction but
but two whether or not it's a cco or not
um
they're probably to be fair to them do
have some time up their sleeve in the
transactions unlikely to occur this
financial year so i won't have any
implications until next financial year
but i would expect them to have an
answer
well i would have expected one by now to
be fair but i would expect one in the
next month the longest
sorry next month
well to be fair to them i mean
they're asking always for advice on i'm
being generous and saying they've had a
month another month probably won't
shouldn't see them through but
i i can't speak for new zealand to be
honest but i would like to think that's
a reasonable time frame
thank you
any other questions at this point
councillor partner um
thank you chair andrew is around there
so so the actual governance of the royal
40s investments is that
that so the ichl will have a
um
the directors on hcl will ever say
so currently
with the agreement of eil
we have uh
through yourselves ultimately the
appointment of the directors down into
the roaring 40s
at this stage but it's more the direct
relationship with that director and the
oversight will be directly to the
holding company rather than through
pylon then eil and then up to ourselves
right
okay thanks
thank you
further questions
okay counselors that brings us to the
recommendations recommendation three is
coming of mute at this point having
already heard from our two submitters
i'll
take one and two first of all before we
launch into any discussion around the uh
final recommendation
one is that we receive the
report
and consultation hearings and
deliberations and receive the
submissions i'll move this is second to
counselor scout
open for comment there is none i'll put
the motion all in favor
aye against
carried
and looking for a move around the final
recommendation
counselor scout you're moving it
thank you
is there a second
i'll second it to get it on the table
it's open for discussion
so i guess some of the consultation was
clunky
to to start off with and
probably not an example of
at our best um but ultimately i guess
why i'm happy to second the
recommendation is that it does
bring
a more direct level of accountability to
icc through ichl
as opposed to icc through pylon or
electricity invercargill
and
that's got to be advantageous
councillor cracker would it not be
advantageous for us to let it lie on the
table until we have that answer
the answer from
audit yeah
andrew
rhiannon do you have a an opinion around
that
the the the reason why you'd think of a
uh an answer um
i think andrew is being generous in his
estimation of a month
because i seem to recall we're still
waiting on close-up on last year's audit
i suppose and we flagged that there's no
time issue realistically from our
perspective from the flag down in the
initial report
my
question would really be why um because
from councils and the holding company's
perspective
we operate as a cco
and we have this discussion all the time
with
commercial operators
who don't want to operate in the cco
space
why
extra transparency we have to report to
council
they they have this risk that
commercial information will be shared
we don't have that concern and i and to
be fair to councillors i wouldn't expect
you to have that concern
um so
that would be my real question
why is the cco
question important to you
do you want it to be or not to be a cco
and and why would you have a preference
one way or the other
preference would be that it was a cco so
that it did have greater transparency
an audit will form a view on that one
way or the other but you'll get
hopefully the greater transparency
through the holding company reporting to
you that too
i guess there's a degree of um
fears around commercial sensitivity it's
going to hold co it's not coming
straight to council so
there's a level of protection around
that and on that point where
as has been raised with me numerous
times i mean christchurch airport is a
cco and they do things
that their council doesn't know about
you know i mean do you want that to
occur
the short answer is no but it's really
it's a false argument to say beneficial
is a bad thing from your perspective
the partners might have different views
but it's you're the one making the
decision
rhiannon
there is one
relevant factor of timing the benefit of
making this decision now means that it
can be reflected within the annual plan
documentation now while this isn't an
absolute requirement it will mean that
we're addressing some of the issues
raised by
mr tribe today in terms of being able to
provide a really clear organizational
structure that is updated from the
long-term plan to reflect this change if
it is made so that's just something to
consider around timing that would need
to be made today if it was going to be
reflected within the annual plan
documentation
thank you
councillor partner thank you chair um
andrew so that's
um
the obvious the obvious end game is to
get eil back to being a lions company
and doing its stuff well
so
otago net is that next to get the shoes
of that
noting that
we're in public
um
there are different alignments uh
between the two investments so to be
fair to everyone
otago net as a lions business is more
aligned with the skill base that we
would have sitting around the il board
than the school base we would have seen
around the holding company board so if
we were to keep a togo net there is some
sense
that the uil board has the skills and
knowledge to be able to manage that most
effectively
um
it's a balancing between those sort of
it is clearly
not a core strategic investment it's a
commercial investment there needs to be
some work done around the nature of the
investment and whether or not it meets
the commercial criteria the council
would like
but in terms of the
ability to best manage that investment
it might be that the skill for that sits
at the ual ball table
thank you
lots of questions or comment
if not we have a motion on the table
it's been moved and seconded i'll put
the motion all in favor i
i
against
carried thank you
it brings us to the
uh
minutes of the community well-being fund
councillor lewis
be a true record of the meeting that we
thought and on the side i'd like to
thank council ludlow for standing there
that short notice didn't make the quorum
on that particular meeting welcome if
you can pull the mic in next time i'll
second that mr chia thank you moved and
seconded any questions comments
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
aye
against
kerry
thank you minutes of the extraordinary
uh performance policy and partnerships
committee meeting from may 10.
somebody like to move there true and
correct council edmondson councillor
scout
matters rising
put that then all in favor aye aye
against
carried
minutes of the uh performance policy and
partnerships committee meeting regular
on may 10.
that's more
all in
favor against
carried
and the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting from
may 24th
moved by reverend cook seconded by
councillor amundsen
comments
put the motion in all in favor
against
carried
right the keeping of animals poultry and
bees bylaw
brianna and jillian welcome along
[Music]
well welcome back rihanna
welcome along jillian
so um
i'll take the report as read and we're
bringing this
bylaw
to you for recommendation for adoption
for consultation
noting the feedback from the district
court which has been incorporated within
the proposed
changes
um there are a number of other small
administrative changes that are
recommended and we recommend that this
be consulted on at the same time as the
dog control bylaw that we'll discuss in
a future paper that has benefits for
ensuring that we have
a wide
ability to publicize this alongside
those so those consultations can work
together
so jillian just has a few comments
around the specifics of the process of
review that we have been through
this was mainly an internal review
leading on from the comments from the
district court we've incorporated those
into the bylaw to ensure that we have
the ability to order the removal of all
livestock if required
we've also incorporated a um
sorry a hearing panel that option within
this spylor so for
people to appeal a decision
there are a number of other
mainly small tweaks uh
that have come through just a
more um
grammar etc and as part of this process
we also
had a consultation with the uh
national member from the rspca who's
responsible for
uh consulting with councils throughout
the country on the keep the keeping of
animal bylaws
thank you
uh councillors there are three
recommendations can i ask first of all
what's the difference between the
process here and
the other by-law sorry two meetings ago
that we didn't feel the need to go out
and consult on why is there a different
threshold treaty or rihanna
sorry which bylaw are we are you
referring to
i think that was actually the noise
control policies
yes so the difference is largely a
matter of status consultation is
required on bylaws under the local
government act and utilizing the special
consultative procedure
um and hence the recommended process
thank you final versus policy
questions counselor sopa it's not a
question i'm happy to move for three
recommendations thank you sir second to
counselor skill
any other questions or comments
counselors like to raise um
bearing in mind that it's going out for
consultation so it's really questions
around processing what's in there
with round one i'll put the motion all
in favor
against
carried thank you
uh and let's just stay where you are
i'll jump over the next item i'll go
straight on to the dog control policy
and um dog control bylaw
um
so again this
policy
it was due for review that has prompted
the internal review which we've
undertaken
as part of that we undertook
pre-engagement with a number of
interested stakeholders and individuals
which was a very useful process and
helped identify um some areas for
improvement within the bylaw
hence we are recommending both the
policy and the bylaws by law to be
adopted for consultation the most
significant element
within the bylaw that is being
considered is
the definition around menacing dogs so
that's to bring it into line with
the um definition within the dog control
act
um that essentially means that there
will just be a difference in how the
menacing and dangerous dogs are dealt
with so jillian may wish to just say
more on that in a moment
there are a number of other factors that
are
just
able to be fixed as part of this review
which are linked to rahui and some other
elements within
the specifics of language within the
bylaw and the policy
as part of the pre-engagement there were
some other suggestions which can be
considered in the future
but no changes are recommended at this
time and that's around elements for
off-leash exercising areas
at present time the recommendation is
that we've got the appropriate level of
resources within the community but that
could be considered by council as a
future as part of a future planning
process
um jillian there may be other
points you would just like to cover
in terms of the changes we've made to
menacing dogs as per the dog control act
um
we can counsel a classify a menacing dog
by deed when a dog has
not been classified as dangerous but
council considers it may pose a threat
to any person stock poultry domestic
animal or protected wildlife because of
an observed or reported behaviour of the
dog
so as such the medicine classification
is at a lower level than the dangerous
classification
the approach recommended allows the
animal control team flexibility and
what requirements it will place on the
owner when classifying a dog as menacing
we've also recommended an introduction
of a process to allow an owner to apply
to council
for the medicine classification to be
removed
the owner would need to be able to show
evidence that they have not received any
infringements in the preceding 12 months
that they've complied with any
obligations imposed on them at the time
that the dog was classified as menacing
and would otherwise have met
um
the criteria to be classified as a
responsible owner
the removal of this classification would
always be at council's discretion
uh this
came about um as we had looked at what
other councils were doing and this is
something that some other councils have
introduced already
and other councils are considering
so just a question of clarification
uh is there a need for somebody seeking
um the removal of that menacing
classification
after a period of time to come before a
committee or is it a decision made at a
staff level
i i would think it's made at a staff
medal
level sorry yes it is yes thanks
again
currently we have people who might
object to a a dangerous classification
or
a medicine class classification and they
can come and go through a hearings
process but that's not what we're
looking at here it's about a natural
reduction after a period of time yes it
is thank you
questions counselors
because we have four recommendations
there councillor lewis
i'd like to move that with all four to
be taken at one once and we make the
positive recommendation
second
mr chair
moved and seconded open for comment
if i may
there was a very robust meeting on the
25th of may and i
and some of these
minor changes have come
coming out of that meeting and i think
the people that took the time after ours
to come to that meeting staff and and
members of the public
it was a good meeting thank you
thank you councillor
there's no further comments uh i'll put
the full resolutions all in favor
aye against
kerry thank you
we all drop back to tab 13 now which is
the media tower seismic and deferred
maintenance
a request from the infracargo city
council charitable trust richard
welcome along
uh just uh take the reporters red just
for a bit of clarity this is we wear
different hats and different parts of
our organizations this isn't a report
around the work that we're doing the
cost or anything around like that
it is simply saying
uh the trust is asking for council to
spend some money on what is a trust
asset
and giving them uh permission to act
upon that as well so just two things
giving council permission to work on on
the icct asset and requesting council to
spend the money that it's already
decided upon so that again that's
something the debate for today
so formality
thank you
counselors there are four
recommendations which i'm happy to move
there's a seconder councillor arnold
thank you
oh you can't
yeah councillor
as a member as a trustee from icct it
might be better that somebody else
um seconds the motion thank you
is there a secondary
reverend cook thank you for that
with that clarity i'll put the motion
all in favor
aye against kerry thanks richard thank
you
the
residence survey report rhiannon and
anna
well michael yeah
could we perhaps take the um council
representation right if you drop down to
oh no she's back
i'll get a revolving door for you yeah
apologies
um
so the
um we're pleased to include the
residence
survey
um for council's information today
um the report covers the
process by which the survey was
undertaken as well as the results
i'll just draw your attention to
a couple of things the first is the
change in methodology which should be
considered when
considering the results
so
previously the residence survey has been
undertaken once every three years as
part of the long-term planning process
and has been done via the phone
now it's part of a national trend that
there is less use of landlines so at
some point the change was going to need
to be made to methodology so we have
made that change like most councils now
to a mixed method approach
so
this means that for this survey was
primarily an online driven approach with
support from
paper copies
phone and street surveying in order to
build the appropriate sample so the
important thing to take away from this
is that when you have an online approach
you're
getting a response from those who are
interested and respond to the postcard
that was sent to every household
and then the sample is weighted to make
up the appropriate population mix this
means that there is
a slant towards perhaps people who have
negative feedback that they may wish to
make
online so that's just one thing to
consider in the results
it does mean that it's more difficult to
track back and compare with previous
surveys but from this point that
methodology
will mean that we can compare the
results going forward more effectively
it also means that we're able to survey
more often
at least once a year and we are working
with the provider now around options for
continuous surveying which would mean
you'll be able to receive more regular
updates on the satisfaction elements of
the surveying
um
on a quarterly basis as part of the
quarterly performance report
so in this survey we were undertaking
a number of things the first thing was
the levels of service
surveying which is part of the long-term
planning process and that's around
asking people
is council doing the appropriate things
that you want them to do are they doing
it to the right level
and do you feel that there's an
appropriate amount that you're paying
for those services
the second thing we were doing was for
the first time asking specifically about
people's satisfaction across those new
kpis that were introduced as part of the
last long-term plan
as well as then providing an opportunity
for
libraries and parks particularly this
time to ask some more detailed questions
that they would they were looking for as
part of their strategic
planning
the final element that was new was
around those kpis that were discussed in
risk and assurance this morning around
the working on working together elements
so those kpis were set ahead of the
surveying being done and when we
discussed with the survey provider
around those questions they just flagged
of course that when you ask a question
like what do people think about is
council or is council not a high
performing council you're going to get a
certain response so that should just be
considered
but we still will be able to track that
trend over time
so hopefully that's just a little bit of
background that gives you
an understanding on how the survey was
done how to interpret the results
i will just also flag that we have been
having conversations with other councils
around their processes and it does
appear to be a national trend at the
moment perhaps it's linked to covert
perhaps it's linked to other elements at
the moment of less than less
sorry lower satisfaction levels with the
democratic process itself
which might be different to the
satisfaction levels with the services
that council provides
so um sorry for that rather lengthy
overview but hopefully it just helps
with the context of reading the report
and i'm happy to answer any questions
thanks ryan and i guess the context is
useful because it is a
different way that the survey's been
carried out this time and across as you
say a different
breadth of subjects being canvassed it
is of course reassuring to see that
still sitting at the top are our parks
and open spaces as they have been for
uh for some time since noah was last
gathering animals
um
councillors uh there are two
recommendations that the
report is received and we note the the
survey somebody like to move
counsellor scout councillor amundson
it's open for comment or questions
reverend cook
um through you mr chair um rhiannon if
we're going to do this on a regular
basis
quarterly sounds terrifying um
sorry
um
will there be
a process which
um restricts the weighting of the online
part to no greater than it was this time
or something along those lines because
i'm quite aware that it could actually
become the dominating
and obscure people's
um
[Music]
the less agitated people's natural
voices
so to speak so
the average person on the street that or
the average person that uses the
services
may actually be overwhelmed by the
disaffected who
are keyboard warriors
and i really think it's important
that
we think about this in advance and
look at you know do we restrict it do we
wait it what do we do to give
everyday people their voice too
um
through uh yes thank you that's a really
good question
the survey providers are experienced
market research company and they are
already weighting some of those elements
within
and they have waited
for population
and they will continue to wait and they
are making those assessments and
judgments as they see the varying
samples over time um if we do move to
continuous surveying that doesn't mean
that we will be pushing out and asking
800 people every quarter to respond what
it means is that there's
a smaller sample that builds over the
year in a cumulative kind of way which
means by the time you get to the end of
the year you've got the whole sample but
it gives you a sense of as you go along
what what people are thinking
thank you
thank you
through the questions
there are none i'll put the emotional in
favor aye aye against
carried
thank you for that
uh the adoption of fees and charges
schedule
which is our
next item
just before we
oh no actually sorry uh rhiannon i'll
let you open
um
so the fees and charges schedule was
consulted on alongside the annual plan
and you heard from submitters on this
issue as part of the annual plan
hearings
providing the fees and charges schedule
now for adoption i will just note
one change to recommendation three and
that is just to note that there are fees
within the dog control area that are in
poundage fees and
due to the technical process
will not be adopted until
this report minutes is received by
council on the 28th of june this doesn't
have a substantive effect because the
fees and charges don't come in until the
1st of july it's just a process element
that it's important to recognize at this
time
so the report notes the feedback that
was had on the fees and charges and it
does note a number of administrative
elements that were picked up between the
time of consultation and now where the
schedule's being brought to you
for adoption
and those changes that are recommended
to be made as a result of that
so
happy to take any questions
on the report
although sorry i will just speak if
that's okay to recommendation for just
to note
that we recommend that those changes not
be implemented until the time of the
coopers creek discussions being
concluded
thank you for that
uh can i start truly perhaps with you
last night councillors received a
an email from mr tribe querying some of
the charges around
dog registration um
do you have a response to the points
that were being raised
certainly through you mr chair so just
to
uh remind
councillors it it can be challenging to
compare
south and district councils area to
icc's area given the urban versus rural
environment
uh there are less call outs for uh dog
barking complaints and least call on
staff for pickup of animals in most
cases anecdotally because the majority
of
dogs in the southland district council
district are working dogs compared to
pets
there's also we have additional costs
that we look after so we have a
animal care facility that south and
district council
rents space only as and when they need
it but we fund that facility we need to
clean that facility daily we need to
feed those animals and exercise them
daily when we do have those impounded
and that does hasn't have an implication
the costs for our after hours service
have increased
uh
over the last 12 months as well and we
have not increased our fee over the last
three years for dog registrations yet
we're seeing an impact from
inflationary pressure even in this
financial year
uh the team in finance had already
scheduled they are we're reviewing
across
uh council uh our fee charges and how we
set those going forward we have a
revenue and finance policy that we
adhere to where there is user pays and
our animal control it is uh challenging
when we do charge the majority of dog
owners yet we still have to pick up
chickens goats sheep
horses excellent cows
which those are not funded as such
and we'll also be making sure
looking into further patricia has
mentioned to mr tribe we are digging
into further into those results that she
had sent through
so
the current
split i think is 93
yes 93 user charges 7
is public good
so
at this stage
there's not a lot that we can do about
that so that's a formal review process
that we've got to go through but i'd
strongly suggest that council does that
because my personal opinion is it's an
unfair burden on on dog owners to
to shoulder um
but the
uh the increase that's that's being
signaled
you've said comes after three years of
not having had an increase
but has there been cost
escalation that the departments have to
meet we're already seeing it in this
year yes what about the
increase in the level of service that's
being required so the type of
calls we're receiving so we also have uh
noted that we're seeing
members of the community being more
agitated so we for safety purposes send
two staff two calls which has been
really valuable especially when they're
involved in incidents that do escalate
and we may need to involve the police
so
for safety when our when we get a call
to pick up a wandering dog etc we always
have two of our staff go out to there
and the same with our after-hours
provider because it's important that
they have the same measures as us
so in summary you're comfortable that
the
fees that are being set around animal
control are appropriate for the level of
service they're expected to deliver i am
yes at this point with the information i
have
thank you for that and thank you uh mr
tribe for the email sent to councillors
last night
uh councillors we've got um four
recommendations as rhiannon pointed out
the fourth
um
deals with the issue that we received
submissions on
uh during the annual plan process from
the residents of corpus creek
and there's a delay there until
discussions with residents are completed
and also noting that the schedule around
animal control
fees doesn't come into effect until this
is formally adopted by council on the
28th of june
is that correct councillor sofa thank
you mr chair i'll move those four
recommendations as a block
okay councillor lewis before we put up
to the vote can i just ask is there any
correlation between the increased number
of wandering dogs and unregistered dogs
within the city
not a conclusion i could draw a sorry
counsellor
at this point in time
i will look to my colleagues at the
back and
see
could you repeat the question please i
was wondering if there is a correlation
between the increased number of
wandering dogs which well the pound has
to pick up and non-registered dogs it
seems if there is i wondered if there
was a one-handed comment on it i just
wonder if there's any correlation
between the
wandering dogs and unregistered dogs
all right by the way i'm just i'm john
i'm the team leader of animal services
so i came along to help out
i wouldn't say there was a direct
correlation i think that
if we look at the overall numbers um
across the country
dog ownership numbers are actually
decreasing and if we look at the our
call-outs they're actually decreasing at
the same same rate so i think that the
percentage of um
call-outs that we're getting are
corresponding with that decrease in
number of dogs around at the moment
does that answer your question it does
john i was trying to get into my mind
the the
increased cost could be caused by
some inconsiderate owners yeah
yeah that's correct thank you there's a
mixture of owners and neighbors i guess
councillor i'm actually i'm still
looking for a secretary for the motion
thank you your worship councillor clark
and then i'll come to you sure back to
the dog fees being raised
um
it doesn't sit well with me i guess that
we are in part raising it because we
just haven't raised anything in the last
three years
and my questions relate to two things
when i came into council
um there was a three hundred thousand
dollar surplus sitting in animal
services
and that was a targeted rate at that
stage now things may have changed since
then
but the big is the question where's the
money on
and if we why should
why should dog owners be subsidizing
services elsewhere so that's one issue i
guess
and the other issue is we get um regular
quarterly updates from the finance team
about how each service is going so i
guess the question is how's it been
going in the last 12 months are we
running a surplus or a deficit and what
was last year's end-of-year result
i would need to get that information to
you counsellor i can't tell you off the
top of my head sure and i understand
that but it's really important if we're
gonna
dogs uh are an important issue for
people and if we want to encourage
people in these difficult times to reach
the dogs
and keep them rested um pushing the fees
up just because we haven't had a fee
increase for some time
if we don't have increased costs that
are pushing us beyond our budgets
would not sit well with me i guess
just to point out that i did ask a
question clarifying that the costs had
gone up
we do have it cost increases to run our
service when you take into account
the
fuel for our vehicles the equipment that
we have to purchase
and our staffing costs and also after
our service provider costs
and i don't have any problems with any
or all of that what i'm suggesting
though is if we were running a surplus
this year projected this year or a
projected surface result for last year
then that undermines the extra cost it
allows us to absorb it without actually
pushing the dog registration up one of
the things that we've discussed in the
past is if you push it up especially in
a high period of
pressure on families will get more
people defaulting and that in itself
creates work
patricia were you able to give any
indication around
how the
figures were tracking if it was towards
the surplus
um
i can't off the top of my head because
it's
embedded in a number of services so we'd
have to pull them apart to be able to
look at dogs solely
along with the rest of the compliance
activities
thank you your worship
oh sorry i'll come back to your council
clerk okay
yes i'd just like to um
raise the issue of cooper's creek and
um
been a long journey that was
uh three terms ago for me
and
there's a is i know it seems backward in
this age of technology but
i find the human presence and when
you've got problems is often turns out
to be the best way to solve it
and this issue was
uh raised because
they're increasing their rates by
i don't know it's a zillion trillion
dollars and um
i think it's just good to have a human
presence there that you want they did
have a ranger there
and
he's
retired
and
they've
made a lot of submissions but it's
just whether you depend i i remember at
primary school
the um
we always had a caretaker on the block
on the school
and it kept the vandalism maybe there
are other social issues involved too but
in that school anyway it kept vandalism
down to a minimum
thank you worship just a reminder we are
delaying any decision until we've
completed discussions with the residents
of coopers creek sorry council o'clock i
hadn't meant to catch off and then i'll
come to you
just to clarification i wasn't seeking
to
get the cost for dog registrations just
to hold the general animal services area
thank you councillor partner i'm just
following on from councillor clarks
mentioning about dog reserves now going
right back
to about 2011 i think it was
those reserve funds um that were
accumulated
under under dogs were actually used to
build the new
uh facility kennel facility down near
the wastewater now i'm
looking through figures i'm under the
understanding that those reserves now
are about in the eight hundred thousand
dollar mark and i'm just wondering
why exactly with council clark why you
would be
putting up fees depends i mean if is it
supposed to break neutral the whole cost
of running
the
doggy enterprise or
uh it just seems that or what would what
would we be using in the long run these
reserve funds that can only be spent
on dog things for
i mean i just yeah
need a bit of a strategy there sir i'm
not sure where the 800 000 figure came
from patricia
um i do believe the 800 figure 800 000
figure came from a piece of information
that was provided to mr tribe which
councillors received that is our
estimate at what it was last year we
know there's a there's a piece of
missing information in that and that is
an allocation of cost towards the dogs
activity which the team are busy going
to be doing within the next 12 months to
ensure their correct costs have been
allocated to those net debt accounts
it's overall council is correct got the
correct net debt position but that one
particular account does not look correct
my question was i guess what are we
going to use that money for
that is in the dog
doggy bank account
so through you mr chair
so that's not the reserve figure that
staff had had to date so we until we
confirm up what exactly that is we would
put forward following that there would
need to be a review of what was
necessary and that couldn't and what was
needed to be funding the service so
at that stage you could look at the fees
and charges if that was appropriate to
fund it from the reserves but we need to
carry through on this work first with
patricia
before we go
any further with deciding how to fund
the service so at the moment our revenue
and financing policy is that it's
93 of our funding needs to come from
fees and charges and seven percent from
rates for our compliance services
councillor clerk
well now the information just given by
my colleague is just absolutely
eye-watering even if it's anywhere near
three or four or five hundred thousand
dollars that we've got in reserves
and and i guess if when as he quite
rightly says if we're not
looking to extend the pound in any shape
and form
why would we just not leave the dog
licensing fees at the same level
and if we need further information on
that i understand you may need that why
don't we just leave this dog
registration issue on the table like
we're doing with cooper's creep until we
get better information
michael
uh through yourself chair um i'd like to
remind councillor there what council
there is a um
project that was in the long term plan
in relation to some
remedial works down at the dog pound to
comply with the
requirements
through the audit that was conducted
we're still completing the final stages
of that and
most of the reserves that were
in in the fund at that time will need to
be sorted as part of that reallocation
i'd say most of them will go towards the
works that have already been conducted
in relation to capital works but there's
also
a few
projects still outstanding in that that
piece of work which we are working
through over the course of the next year
so i'm hoping that that remedial works
will complete be completed in the next
year
that's around the exercise yard and the
likes that is correct thank you chair
that's the answer i was seeking yeah
okay
any other questions or comments
counselor cracker um
i'm actually leaning a bit towards um
councillor clark on this issue if we do
have
the surplus there i would sooner like to
see clarity
uh around it
rather than just hiking the
cost
on a perhaps
or that we know that there has been
inflation we don't we can't quantify how
much
that's actually going to have an impact
on on it yet
yeah i would certainly see a similar
uh recommendation there's number four
there a request to delay the
implementation of
the dog registration fee until we have
clarity around it
councillor podinger um
well
as i said before i'm quite happy with
the answer that
michael has presented because it now
signifies a use for those
dog reserves money and they're not
sitting there idly
while we're putting up fees if they are
being used in capex and stuff like that
then i can accept that that is that's
what it's there for we've used it in the
past
and as long as we keep improving
facilities expanding that is fine it's
when we don't have any idea what we're
going to use them for then that's what i
worry
okay thank you
councillor lewis thank you for all of
that we could actually create a hiatus
for just one year and see what
transpires with the costs that uh mr day
has been talking about
did you indicate you wanted to speak
counselor club well i guess there's two
things for me on that i'd be quite happy
if the rates just stay the same for the
next 12 months while we sort out where
we're spending the surplus
um but
as we've already been indicated by
staff
we don't have any understanding of how
much that capex work will be costing
and we don't have any idea of whether we
ran a surplus last year or whether we're
going to run a surplus this year and if
we're running a surplus in the last two
years why would we be pushing the rates
up if we've already got
a nice nest egg there to do the the kbx
work at the at the site
just doesn't make any sense to me
talking about rates are you talking
about the fees just yeah just why the
fees to the to the dog owners would go
up
thanks
and i'm quite happy for you know to have
that set on the table like the cooper's
creek one so that staff can give us a
greater degree of information
councillor sopa
well mr chair if there is a feeling for
many councillors to add a recommendation
five as the mover of the motions i
invite someone to add something that we
could perhaps discuss
counselor clark
happy to do that
so to treat it very much like a
recommendation for
michael can you answer
what the potential impact on the annual
plan is likely to be from
yes three years
through yourself chair the calculation
in relation to those fees has as my
colleague at the top indicated was based
on the percentages
in relation to the fee
fees recovering of 93 to 7 percent
any change in that would have an impact
of altering that balance if those fees
were not uh fees were not approved as
they
are proposed
so that would mean that the seven
percent that is currently rates paying
would need to go up it to compensate in
relation to that which would recalculate
the 6.53
that is something i can't quite do on
the fly at the moment sorry council but
it would have an impact it might be
minor but it would definitely have an
impact on that 6.53 so i just want to
bring your attention to that and
there has been a calculation because it
is the 93
that my colleague raised in relation to
operating cost percentage that it's
covering in relation to the fee increase
councillor clark just as a final comment
on that
i wouldn't expect
the wider community to pay for
a reduction or a holding of dog fees i
think they need to be user pays as was
suggested by trudy
um
but we don't have enough information i
don't think
i'd be happy to hear what michael's got
saying and what some of the other stuff
i've got to say well
they have some numbers around this
so you're suggesting around that delay
until there's a clarification around
your numbers is that yours it may not
take long
a little bit like we're doing with that
with the cooper's creek one
just give the staff a moment
i think that might be useful look
councillors um
i don't want to catch the the staff
without having had a chance to discuss
this for just a couple of minutes i'll
take a a brief five minute adjournment
councillor pottinger oh look there was
one whoa while we're we're most i'll
throw another curveball in
okay during the risk and assurance
meeting this morning
we talked about 106 000
of unclaimed or unrecovered
dog registration fees now
if they weren't to be recovered
uh and had to be written off now
obviously that's going to impact um what
michael was talking about before as well
correct so what stage do we
again do we do we carry the carry that
as an as a as a
revenue and then all of a sudden that
has to be written off
good point and bearing in mind that that
figure of uh
um unregistered dogs or dogs not being
re-registered is going up so i'll call a
five-minute adjournment council as we
will be underway at 10 2 i don't want to
come
we'll just fire up the stream once again
okay for those on the live stream uh
thank you for bearing with us
councillor abbott you can turn your um
camera back on
we'll uh reconvene
who was taking the lead trudy yes
through you mr chair so just to
reconfirm to council or to the committee
we do have an obligation to advertise on
monday uh as part of the dog control act
it's a legitimate slit of requirement
that we advertise a change in fees so we
do need some form of decision today
uh it's roughly a five percent increase
and that does reflect the increased cost
to the service to run the operation
from the staffing right through to the
after hours etc etc
and we
we have
understood to date that we had available
approximately 160 to 180 000 in reserve
to work on that additional capital works
but patricia and her team will obviously
be doing a deeper dive to analyze that
but there wasn't uh
significantly more than that available
and just to recap
portion of that
reserve has been
attributed to some capex yes
and it all is also potentially being
used to fund a short fall in
registration fees from people defaulting
potentially yes
thank you
so councillor clark we were with you and
you were seeking
so based on that advice i'm still
opposed to the to the uh increasing
things because um
it's all very well to say that our
current charges have gone up five
percent but if i don't have a year-end
result for last year for animal services
what happens if they made a five percent
surplus last year and we don't have that
we don't have the projected
outcomes for animal services for this
year as well
so it wouldn't be right to me to be
pushing
the rate for dog registrations up five
percent only to find out at the end of
the year that we've got another healthy
surplus in there
very well we're just a couple of weeks
away from the end of the year as well
sure but i'm sure that finance team can
give us an indication of where we're at
with that it wouldn't be too hard we get
those traffic light reports anyway by
service
do we get it for we get it full water
services we get it for animal services
i'm not getting a lead from you there
nobody
well i mean i i guess i'd i've already
said i would like that to be left on the
table
if we can leave um
the cooper's creek stuff on the table
then i'm open to them coming back
staff coming back with some information
about what last year's figures were and
what the current year's figures were
to safeguard that we're not pushing up
rates just because we haven't had it for
three years
but again it's up to my colleagues to
decide that
mrs hadley do you want to comment on
that uh mr chair i'd just point out
there's a difference between the
situation with cooper's creek and the
situation with dog control
and so far as the dog controllers um
more legislatively required set out
treaties referred to the need to send
the notices out on monday
councillor arnold then councillor
passenger and then his worship
uh i'm not understand i'm sitting like
this
all right
your fingers are loaded but you ever go
to todd's auction house walked away with
something that you didn't want
to see the furniture i've got at home
[Laughter]
councillor partner
look
in closing we've we've had the
explanation from michael about the use
of reserves and that's i believe has
satisfied
us to move on with the increased dog
fees if the reserves build up again we
can then improve our facilities again
and as long as we're doing that
reinvesting the money then i'm happy
with that we're not sitting on stuff so
i've been convinced that we are using
the money and so i'm happy to move that
this increase is justified and hopefully
this can stay like this for say another
three years well we don't need a motion
because there's all right yeah no no but
i'm happy that it can say like that and
thank you in three years time look at it
your worship
yes
i
i find there's quite a difference
between cooper's creek and dog control
and
because we're looking at
how do we solve this problem in a
long-term way otherwise it's just going
to keep coming back and coming up for
council
reserves and council debate
as it has been
carrying on now and
we had this problem in auckland sorry to
harp on about it but it's
it's the the main experience i've had of
this issue
is that
they've we've got to um
[Music]
solve it and and we've had this problem
we had um a little settlement like that
at miuraway a little settlement like
that at hobsonville
and
they were
built without a permit
they've got the right to live there but
you worship
no one is questioning the delay over
what's happening uh with cooper's creek
while we continue the discussions with
with the residents out there that's
not been challenged by any councillors
so far
so there's no action being taken at this
stage on the residents of cooper's creek
until there's been further discussion
and more clarity
okay i accept that
thank you
um
so let's see if i can bring this to a
head um
counselor clark
got the right c there um
is suggesting uh a delay to the
implementation to any changes in the
dog registration fee
is there a seconder for such a proposal
okay
seconded by councillor arnold
we've all had a reasonable bite of it so
i'll test that to see if there is any
willingness for that to be added
and then it'll form part of the overall
suite of recommendations if everybody's
comfortable with that
okay those in support of adding
that uh a delay to the implementation of
any
change to dog registration fees please
say aye
against
i declare the motion lost
so we come back to the
uh
remaining four
um
recommendations that have been moved and
seconded
is there any further questions or
comments around that
if not i put that motion all in favor
aye against
yes i'm opposed
would you like your vote recorded
counselor that would be great thank you
likewise please and councillor arnold
and councillor abbott
thank you
that brings us to the annual plan solid
waste additional funding updates
welcome along peter patricia
thanks for first of all uh getting the
information together in in a short time
frame i know that we sought some
clarification following
uh deliberations from the last
extraordinary pvp around the annual plan
peter
i'll take the uh reporters right so if
you refer to pages 2272.73
that's where the report is now um
i think the questions around is why
there's an increase in
costs and that's related to an increase
in
materials going to landfill plus
increases per tonne
of those costs so there's increases in
the etcs
there's increases in
transport costs and
transfer costs there's these
increases in um
across the board in terms of
uh
the
the transfer station management
the there's a cost in terms of increases
in terms of the collection of the
bins so the bins are actually measured
per bin collection not per weight
so then we've got additional bins
as the population rises there's um
an increase of generally around about
five percent that we're forecasting in
terms of the tonnage
recovery there's been a slight drop in
recycling but there's no material
difference in terms of the overall cost
thank you patricia anything you'd like
to add
so i just want to clarify one point
which was raised to me this morning that
in the paper which you received
fortnight ago at the extraordinary ppp
meeting in relation to the recovery
potential recovery from southland
district council
that amount has already been factored in
to the rates increase at that point that
staff were advising
so it was not if it was if we were
budget we were budgeting that we would
recover that amount so i think there was
a use of the word if that was
a little confusing
thank you
councillor pottinger
no
well you asked the question on the first
instance
about the waste increase yes
yes yes i did and and obviously i was
focusing on figures that i've been given
and
that's since been clarified i mean
the staff
staff report explains why we have the
1.17 increase it's made up
you've got uh cost of doing business
and you've got
an increase in waste we're producing per
capita now i can understand the cost of
doing business going up you've got
levies government taxes around the
emission trading scheme
you've got the cost increases from
contractors i mean diesel alone would
explain a part of it
but what i what i
can't come to grips with is the increase
in weight
per capita and the reason for this is
there's a piece of legislation
government legislation called the waste
minimization act 2008
and what that does
it
it instructs councils through what's
called a waste minimization management
plan that they have to adopt
to address
and minimize waste going to landfill so
on one hand
we are forecasting quite rightly because
the figures show it a five percent
increase in waste that we're creating
you know on the other hand
we're supposed to be reducing waste now
um
right so so who does this well the waste
minimization plan
is done by a joint committee which is
wastenet
now they created this new plan
in
june 2020
and
that was the last time waste net ever
met
the record show that's two years ago so
during this hiatus
we have had
no initiatives for waste minimisation
we've had
no bin inspections we've had no waste
audits
and we've been racking up as we see now
in front of us causing
seven hundred thousand dollars
1.17 rate increase
this is an accumulative result
of basically doing nothing in fact
if you read the forward
of the waste minimization plan and i
wrote it down because it
baffles me with it the plan adopts a
holding pattern position providing waste
net with the opportunity to understand
the overall direction of where the waste
sector in new zealand is heading and how
we can best position ourselves to meet
the challenge well unfortunately this
is actually true in effect because
that's the last we heard of waste net
and two years of hiatus
sees us
reeling with these extra charges now
the other thing
that baffles me as well is that in the
gate levy at ab lime there's a 10
waste net administration fee
now this is applied to every ton
that goes in from southland and to
a b lime
now if we go back to that june
25 meeting
2020
in the agenda it lists the financials
and that fun on the
[Music]
in 2019 2019
was
six
hundred and nine thousand dollars that
fund
now i've worked it out uh
it would now be around 1.2 million
dollars so we've got that money sitting
there
in a fund in waste net that that
council is a major participant in
now i can't quite see it's like the dog
thing we sorted that out we had money in
reserves
and we've worked out that's been used
whatever this money is not being used
along with the
there's also another levy
the the government charges and that's 30
a ton well it used to be 20
and that's the
levy on anything going to landfill and
what they do is that you apply for a
rebate and they give you half it back
which you're supposed to spend
on initiatives to stop
to divert waste that's what it's all
about we have not spent a cent of that
and i worked out there's 240 000 of that
sitting there not being used
that can't offset rates but it can help
us it can be used by staff to try and
reverse these trends
the thing is that you might argue or
someone might argue that we can't touch
this 1.2 million dollars
well back when i was in the old days
when i was on waste net
this particular fund was used
to offset fluctuations in the ets levy
so what would happen is it was going up
and down and everywhere and that money
was applied we currently
spend
1.3 million a year
on a mission training scheme levies
so
i just would like to see us
being able to get some some of our money
back out of that fund that is just not
being used and it's creeping up to
a monumental amount
so there we go
so can i come back to the are you
comfortable that the additional 700 000
of funding that was requested is
required that is required yes that is
justified um i don't like the way it's
got there and the fate and the fact that
it's from not addressing our excessive
waste
and our remedy is to
use some of that 1.2 million dollars
thank you
so there are three recommendations there
as a result of the report that it's
received determine that the amount is
required
and also the note that is item three i'm
happy to move those three
recommendations if this is second
second that counselor skill thank you
it's open for discussion
councillor clark yeah just want to add
to what rankings just said i mean he's
the expert in this field as far as i'm
concerned um
and i wonder whether the no bin
inspections has had an impact as well
because um a lot of stuff that we pay
for is weight related
i'm certainly going to av line of this
and so we've got too many glass bottles
frames like in the wrong container
that's where the the waste cost kicks in
um so yeah i think that there's several
things that are driving up
i think there's a an occupational health
and safety matter around the bin
inspections
that has been raised previously and
there's a resourcing
uh issue as well
just just to answer that point but
any further questions or comments
sorry that was it you counsellor
yeah i know just just a comment back i
mean i've heard the chief executive
previously say that um
it was a resourcing issue hard to find
people to do the work not heard of the
health and safety things um
you can get predictive grabs and what
have you to do it i know it's not their
most perfect job but
given that we're one of only a few
councils that actually only runs two
bins
where others run three
um the glass is an issue for us if you
get in the right bin we can isolate it
if we don't it adds weight to the ab
line
the costing i suppose
thank you
councillors as uh councillor pottinger
um i'm i'm just looking at steve did you
want to speak steve something no right
look i want to talk about
the bin inspections now i've found out
that council was approached back in 2019
about
uh subcontracting that out having
another service provider for bin
inspections and turned it down
now
that would solve
a lot of health and safety issues where
it gets
where
you know we have to take it on board so
you know these
these things need to be explored
i'm informed by the team that a report
is coming to the next
infrastructure meeting
that will address
quite a few of the issues i've raised
today so i i have confidence in that but
what i want to do now is i mean i'd like
to move actually
that we do use some of that 1.2 million
dollars in the waste net fund that would
be contrary to the motions that already
said on the table
i'll move an amendment
sorry i'm also advised to potentially
contrary to the waste net agreement
i understand what you're saying and
maybe that's an issue that you can raise
when the report comes to infrastructural
services we are setting the rates here
and we've been told it is compounding so
and you said you were satisfied with the
answer i was i was satisfied with why
the rates had why the amount had been
achieved
and now i'm offering a solution
counselor sopher
thanks mr chia i was just going to
agree with what you had said that since
we now know there is a
report on the
holistic issue coming to infrastructure
it seems sensible to leave any further
discussion to infrastructure in light of
that report
and i think
it would be good to see perhaps some of
the suggestions around what can be done
to
see some positive waste of minimisation
happening and enact some of the funds
that have may or may not be because we
don't know because we haven't seen them
built up at that point
but at this stage it was around the 700
000
dollars that was additional funding that
was being requested and that's what
forms part of this motion so there are
three recommendations that have been
moved and seconded
and i'll test them by putting it to a
vote all in favor
aye
against i'm against
and then the fact that i've just
mentioned that we're not doing all
practically possible to solve that so
you'd like that recorded yes please and
councillor arnold
thank you
and the same for me as well thanks
councillor clark
thank you councillors that brings us on
to tab 18 which is council
representation of the lgnz agm
good afternoon again of all councillors
um
it's a small report to bring home the
public part of this meeting
as you will be aware there is the local
government new zealand agm coming up uh
council is entitled to be represented
and vote at the agm on the various
remits
by a presiding delegate and then three
alternate delegates
it has been recommended by the chairs
group that they be comprised of the
two committee chairs and the two deputy
committee chairs but
this committee needs to determine who is
the presiding delegate
and then of course provide the three
alternate delegates and it is up to this
committee to make that decision
i'm of course happy to answer
any questions
thank you
are there any questions for mr morris
council
the fact that this was uh decided at a
cheers meeting
and not by the full council as to who
will go
represent the council at this particular
meeting i think that's a little bit
unfair because
what i see is like a small group
making a decision for themselves if you
like
to actually do this so um you don't
think it should be something that i can
say
counselor sorry i don't mean to
interrupt i know the cheers group did
not determine this it is for my
reporters left it open for this
committee to determine uh what i was
relying was what the chairs group had
recommended
be the makeup of the delegates this
committee is free to decide who they
would like to be the presiding member
and who they would like to be the
alternate
delegates and if it's not clear in my
report that that is the case then i
apologize thank you it's also worth
reiterating that it's a zoom meeting so
it's not hitting away anyway
so we're looking for a
presiding delegate and an alternate and
a recommendation there are three
alternates sorry three alternates i
believe
you can have up to three
so your council is entitled to be
represented by four people
at the presiding delegate and up to
three delegates but you can determine to
have
one
or two
silence random wheel golf
council around this gonna say it does
say
the report does say the agm is to be
held by way of zoom only
okay
good enough
well i think traditionally the mayor
should
coming up
um as we did before last year we will
bring those remnants to council for
guidance on how the voting is to is to
go
my personal view is that um i mean i
don't need to be involved in this but um
personal viewers at least the two chairs
should be involved there's two of the
four
and then i think we should open the
floor for anybody else that might want
to be involved in that includes the
deputy chairs but there might be other
people that are interested as well
councillor sopa thank you mr chair can
we clarify who was the presiding
delegate at the last agm councillor
crackit was the alternate how was the
alternate
thank you
perhaps it would be straightforward if
um you asked mr chair
who was interested in being the
presiding delegate and who was
interested in being
one of up to three alternate delegates
and that might narrow the field somewhat
fair enough is anybody interested in
being the presiding delegate show of
hands
i've put mine up
just cash you couldn't see alex
again it's about representing the views
that council is to um
put forward through uh a meeting with de
hall
do we nominate the same people who did
it last year then we have no nominations
as you i'm so i'm i mean
we're open
i was going to nominate
just fine
to put something on the table what what
time of the day on that thursday
we don't know oh you don't know but it
is the thursday
michael do you know no i don't have an
exact time for when that's starting
unfortunately
counselor
thanks mr chair just just to put
something on the table um
because it is late and it doesn't seem
like it's
something we need to spend a great deal
of time on can i can i nominate
councillor ludlow as the presiding
delegate
and councillors
amundsen
crackit and pottinger as the alternate
delegates
i'm unavailable that day so
that knocks it down yeah same
unavailable on that thursday well that
narrative
considerably to the case
potentially these same representatives
that you had last year you're the last
people standing i nominate councillor
ludlow as presiding delegate councillor
crackit as alternate delegate so you're
a secretary for the motion reverend cook
thank
you this is headlining sorry
okay it's a small item uh well there's a
recommendation uh that the reports
received and that's uh myself
registered as council's presiding
delegate and councillor crackers
alternate as per last year put that all
in favor
against
uh
do you like your vote recorded your
worship
thank you kerry
oh sorry
alex i apologize i missed your hand
there
yeah that's fine um i think it was just
really important to clarify that the way
and i'm not sure if you you had probably
already but i've just obviously had to
step out and get charlie and now i'm
back again um
that we as a round table will have the
opportunity to feed in and discuss
everything yeah we had carried that out
we have connected that yeah so it'll
literally just be pushing button
indeed
i look forward to seeing what it is
because it wasn't a successful presumed
agm last time
was anybody who wasn't part of the
cheese group because i do take um heed
of what councillor arnold had put
forward um don't want it to ever feel
like it is a closed group and that it's
not um
as part of the chairs and would really
like to open it the floor to
after going through a prolonged period
of social awkwardness uh we've had a
motion and it's been passed
okay
uh if there was somebody who was busting
at the seams to go through online
torture um they've lost that opportunity
thank you that was the same as we had
last time and
i think from memory i went to the
conference anyway yes this is just an
online meeting sir
although you weren't there for the agm
on the sunday
i said i'll be departing saturday
morning yes
um that brings us to the activities
report
[Music]
so it's after five o'clock so in the
interest of time i'm very
happy to take questions um the highlight
for me or that is just to
say that there's a general feeling of
eagerness on the departments of wanting
to get back to normal so a lot of the
focus now is about
what it's going to take to get back to
normal to get back to what our service
levels used to be
and reconnect with those people so
there's a lot of anticipation out there
we're not there yet though
we are still very much reduced services
across our facilities um but there is a
bit of optimism out there so happy to
start questions
thanks richard
councillor pottinger
i'm very wary of reports coming right at
the end when of a long meeting day so
yeah
i look forward to your activities report
which which went through pretty quickly
um
noted thanks for that
the recommendation is that the
report is received um i'm guessing
illness still plagues us and how we're
able to deal with delivery sometimes but
we have i think
coped
admirably through the past two years and
particularly when other councils have
had to close their doors
and through mr given the environment
that we're in at the moment the general
feeling of community we're in exactly
where you'd expect us to be in terms of
performance if there are people who
think that the whole pandemic's finished
um i've got a wife who works in a high
school who'll tell you otherwise
so i'll move that the reports received
council safari second dinner i'll second
that and i'll also just say um
compliments to these staff in various
parts of our organisation who have been
doing things like adding extra programs
and thinking outside the square to keep
activities going and keep them current
and
attract people to um participate that
has been um
that has been noticed and commented on
during the covert times
even an entertainment event on friday
night at the civic how exciting
another one tomorrow
okay it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor all right
against
kerry thank you for that uh oops went to
risk and assurance there we've now got
the um in committee portion of
this evening's meeting small move that
we go into public excluded to receive
the minutes of the pe
session of the community well whoops
well-being fund a confirmation of
minutes from the pe session of
performance policy and partnerships may
10 and the great south review of
governance process
reasons for going into public excluded
are outlined on the paper
put that all in favor aye against carrie
to those who've been following us on
live stream well done on getting this
far
thank you for your interests we are now
you